[Musique]
porte de versailles salon international
de la radiotélévision le premier salon
de la couleur à trois semaines du
lancement officiel en france de la
télévision en couleurs
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
êtes séduit par la couleur ben ça change
ce nouveau ballet très jolie juste un
mois j'étais venu espèces on voit le
speg et je trouve ça vraiment joli c'est
une très jolie chaud je trouve que c'est
un ami dames et ma foi ça me paraît
assez extraordinaire change pas
tellement du noir et blanc
on s'est quand même plus sévère je pense
que ça a certainement un très grand
allié et que dans quelques temps de
noircir complètement disparu
les fleurs sur la première fois mais je
trouve que c'est bien ça nous paraît
peut-être pas très net est très clair
mais je suis sûr qu'en s'habituera
merveilleux oui vous venez de l'entendre
tout ce qu'ils ont vu le constate la
couleur apporte au petit écran une
nouvelle dimension
[Musique]
trois procédés de télévision en couleurs
existe actuellement dans le monde
le ntc américain le pal allemand et le
secam séquentiel à mémoire procédé
français choisis par de nombreux pays
dont l'union soviétique et les pays de
l'est ce procédé mis au point par henri
de france
sinon ile-de-france procédé français
ccam de télévision couleur c'est votre
enfant oui mesure ne fait c'est c'est
mon enfant à l'origine mais bien entendu
d'après lui faire un développement
intensif et ce développement ne peut se
faire qu'avec des équipes d'ingénieurs
de grande valeur et de grande et boubou
quand et comment avez-vous inventé ce
procédé
eh bien vous savez dans le métier de
l'électronique auquel j'appartiens
depuis près de 40 ans j'ai pas vue de
stimuler de révolution c'est à dire ça a
été constamment une évolution en
ensemble de perfectionnement qui ajoutés
les uns aux autres villes 10 par faire
un produit et qui devient définitif
alors pour le secam ça a été aussi le
résultat d'études que nous avions déjà
fait pendant près de dix ans avant elle
c'est à dire que en ce qui me concerne
et en ce qui concerne beaucoup de mes
collaborateurs ca fait dans le temps
nous travaillons la couleur est ce que
dans l'avenir il n'y aura plus qu'un
seul procédé de télévision en couleur
d'après vous non je ne le pense pas mais
il ne faudrait pas croire que c'est
grave n'est ce pas on a écrit beaucoup
et on a dit beaucoup sur la question
fait c'est extrêmement facile les
systèmes sont très voisins et systèmes
pal et secam sont très voisins nous
avons résolus complètement le système du
transcodage ya aucune difficulté pour
les échanges le programme tout ça a été
vérifié le pose aucun problème
d'autre part vous allez avoir des
récepteurs qui pour recevoir le palais
le secam
et même le téléspectateur ne s'en
apercevra même pas je parle de ceux qui
sont sur des régions frontières ne peut
recevoir l'un ou l'autre des systèmes ya
automatiquement le récepteur se mettra
en harmonie avec le système utilisé
monsieur de france comment envisagez
vous l'avenir de la télévision en
couleurs en france eh bien c'était une
question qui m'intéresse beaucoup et
évidemment moi je vois un très grand
avenir à la télévision couleur le pense
que tout est en couleur maintenant aux
pages le cinéma et le mêle aussi l'âme
amateurs notamment enfin tout le monde
cherche fait des films de vacances en
couleurs lors je pense que la couleur et
une évolution normale
donc je crois un très grand
développement de la couleur à très
grands développements locaux leur encore
faut-il si vous voulez que les prix les
prix soient convenables ça allait
acheter un poste alors dans les médias
trop cher
pour l'instant j'en viens depuis une
dizaine d'années en noir et blanc
veuille soit amorti la vie animale déjà
à faire la télévision de shell en noir
alors que la couleur cessant de l'enfant
pour l'instant on va les moyens je ne
payerai vous avez acheté un poste alors
je pense se penche et encore un petit
peu oui
alors allez vous acheter un poste pas
tout de suite aimé ça viendra
[Musique]
pour produire en série des récepteurs
couleurs les constructeurs français ont
dû livrer une véritable course contre la
montre
[Musique]
en moins d'un an ils ont installé des
chaînes de production un peu partout en
france pour pouvoir gagner la bataille
de la couleur arme principale de cette
bataille le sucre 4 différence
fondamentale entre le tube cathodique
noir et blanc et couleur bien sûr il ya
beaucoup de différences
mais avant d'en arriver à l'accueil peut
être intéressant de passer rapidement en
revue l'évolution des tubes pour la
télévision depuis les 20 dernières
années
depuis le premier tube rond de 1947
jusqu'où tu actuelle en voyant que les
tubes ont changé d'abord de forme ils
sont devenus rectangulaire
ils ont changé également de profondeur
de façon à permettre la réalisation de
récepteurs - encombre et nous arrivons
ainsi à au dernier né de l'amour des
productions françaises le tube couleurs
les deux fabricants français ont décidé
d'assurer dès 1967
la mise en route d'une production sur le
système des tubes dit à masquer perforé
la seule à être réalisable
industriellement aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
et
sur les grolles la fabrication en série
des fausses couleurs vous êtes exposés
des problèmes différents la fabrication
des postes couleur au noir et blanc
nous avions des différences absolument
fondamental car fabriqué des leasers en
couleurs c'était pratiquement fabriquer
3 télévisée en scène mais vous voyez que
ce problème a été totalement maîtrisé et
la visite que nous faisons aujourd'hui
la cite la chaîne de fabrication qui
vous et montrez vous pour suffisamment
que nous sommes dès le début de
septembre à mai à offrir au public des
téléviseurs actuellement fabriqué en
série
le prix moyen d'un récepteur fuller
actuellement est de 5000 francs ne
concerne pas que ces prix élevés vont
freiner le développement de la
télévision en couleurs il est évident
qu'au départ la télévision couleur
s'adressera aux couches aisées de la
population
cela dit il faut que vous sachiez que la
france étant le promoteur d'un système
international de quelques couleurs
l'industrie française se devait de
donner aux téléspectateurs français
une image d'une exceptionnelle qu'elle
elle se devait de plus de donner à ses
téléspectateurs sur un même appareil
couleurs l'ensemble des émissions 819
ligne et 625 ligne couleur et noir et
blanc et lee a réussi et c'est au départ
une technique chère
il faut tenir compte également en france
des conditions fiscales dont le public
connaît bien les incidences de taux de
la tva est aussi l'ensemble des marges
de commercialisation qui vont de lusine
de l'industriel à la vitrine du
revendeur monsieur de la loi vous êtes
commerçant vous représentez
tout le commerce de détail radio
télévision à trois semaines du lancement
à jean couleurs comment se présente le
marché ce qu'il ya beaucoup de commandes
il y a surtout beaucoup de personnes
intéressées par la télévision couleur
que je ne pense pas qu actuellement il y
énormément de commande et pour quelles
raisons d'après vous est ce que c'est
une raison de prix essentiellement une
des raisons essentielles et évidemment
l'offre est relativement élevé des
appareils est ce que justement le
commerçant net est peut-être un peu
fautif dans cette affaire aux absa lui
ment pas pour la raison suivante si vous
avez deux catégories le prix dans la
production actuelle certains fabricants
ont choisi les prix conseillés et le
concède à ce moment là à quelque chose
comme 25 % en or que la plupart des
grandes banques auront choisi le prix de
cession net du fabricant ou au vendeur
le sang ce dernier le soin d'eux est de
déterminer le prix de détail
or les prix suggérés par ces mêmes
fabricants nous laisse environ 20% ce
qui est insuffisant ce qui représente
par exemple pour un poste de valeur de
5000 francs qui vont du 5000 francs
public
ce large de 1000 francs au solaire par
exemple ils font effectivement et 20%
sont insuffisants si l'on tient compte
que la large moyenne des frais généraux
dans nos entreprises représentent
environ 20 25 concerts ya également un
autre problème important à ce que le
commerce détail s'est préparé un
dépannage des postes couleurs depuis
plusieurs mois en collaboration avec du
rdr tous les fabricants la formation
professionnelle des adultes nous avons
effectivement appelé des milliers de
professionnels qui ont répondu
d'ailleurs positivement pour renforcer
leurs connaissances techniques et ils
ont même été jusqu'à faire des
investissements de plusieurs millions
d'appareils de mesure rappelle qu en
faire face voilà maintenant ce qui
imposera
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
différences entre un téléviseur noir et
blanc et un téléviseur couleur ça c'est
évident il ya une très grosse différence
surtout au point de vue complexité de
l'appareil
lampard complexité pour les réglages à
l'exode de visage et par l'installateur
alors est ce que le téléspectateur
pourra lui même faire quelques réglages
étaient bien il aura très peu de
réglages à faire dans la télé couleur
qui seront rigoureusement les mêmes que
sur un téléviseur noir et blanc c'est à
dire les théiers boutons qui sont à sa
disposition
mais évidemment pour l'installateur
c'était votre histoire
alors là vous avez une série de boutons
à l'intérieur d'une petite partie cachée
qui comporte une trentaine de couteau
qui est obligatoirement à régler à la
mise installation d'appareils et que le
téléspectateur ne dois absolument bouger
changer en général comme en ouverture
cécile préparer à l'avènement de la
couleur sur le plan des programmes
c'était presque plus délicat dans la
mesure où je crois vraiment que la
couleur ajoute une dimension nouvelle
aux émissions et là aussi l'effort a été
considérable puisque depuis plus d'un an
les réalisateurs s'attaquent à ce
problème de la couleur lors le public va
être juge et ce matin encore je voyais
l'une des nombreuses émissions que nous
avons préparée dans cette perspective en
me rendant compte tout ce que cela
implique des difficultés ce film sur
tolède el greco qui bien que le public a
des références dans cette affaire c'est
ce que sont les couleurs du greco c'est
ce que sont les brûleurs d'une ville
comme solène et ne pouvons pas nous
permettre de lui donner des images qui
souhaitent en deçà de ses couleurs du
greco au delà ou différentes et pas
davantage de couleurs de tollens cela
donne la difficulté des problèmes que
nous avons à résoudre qui est beaucoup
plus considérable suivi du noir et du
blanc mais je crois que de ce qui a été
fait de l'expérience accumulée par nous
même de celles que nous avons bénéficié
du fait que d'autres ont commencé à
gauche pensé spécialement de raemerich
nous avons là un un ensemble de 2
ference d'expérience qui nous
permettront je crois en commençant le
1er octobre de donner au public une
couleur intéressante belle et qui
ajoutera une dimension supplémentaire au
plaisir qu'il éprouve à regarder la
télévision
ce lancement de télévision couleur a dû
exiger de gros efforts sont en
financiers oui mais la rtf dans le passé
avec lui à connaître les efforts
semblables
lorsqu'il s'est agi de lancer la
télévision et ce moment là le lancement
a été supporté au fond parce qu'ils ne
détenaient que la radiodiffusion sommes
aujourd'hui un petit peu en présence
d'un phénomène à l'homme ce que je puis
dire c'est que grâce à un ensemble de
mesures qui ont été prises aussi bien au
sein de le fisc à l'échelon du
gouvernement la garantie est donné que
ce développement de la couleur ne se
fera pas au détriment de ceux qui
assurent aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel
les ressources de l'office c'est à dire
il est en tort d'appareils de
radiodiffusion et des détenteurs de
l'appareil de télévision en noir et
blanc en noir et blanc
je crois pouvoir dire que le budget de
l'année prochaine de ce qu'il se
présente le laissera intactes les
chances les possibilités des noir et
blanc et que mon dieu
les perspectives de l'office de ce point
de vue ne va pas décevoir son public ici
de la couleur ni celui du noir et blanc
la mire couleur que vous pourrez voir le
mois prochain
c'est en effet à partir du 1er octobre
que le rtf diffusera 12 heures de
programmes couleur par semaine y compris
les actualités télévisées
en attendant voici en noir et blanc un
extrait du cookie amoureux de jean
christophe averty
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]